the carolina panthers reportedly have
made a coaching hire the three primary
candidates were eric the enemy josh
mcdaniels and matt roll and the winner
is matt rule the baylor head coach going
to carolina your first thoughts on that
decision chris well shocking one i had
been i had been hearing and believing
that kind of josh mcdaniels was the
leader in the clubhouse in carolina two
the other thing we know mike i think you
know this as well
all signs were pointing towards people
in the know in the nfl were telling you
matt rule to the new york giants that he
was the number one candidate on the
giants you know search list so this is a
huge shake up this is big time i mean
matt rule was supposed to go what
interview for the giants job tomorrow he
doesn't even get there get out of the
building in carolina so i guess that's
where i'm shocked
that's the way you do it though if
that's the guy you want you got to get
the deal done before he leaves because
once he's gone he may never come back so
what do you think matt rule will bring
to the carolina panthers based upon what
we've seen from him
primarily if not almost exclusively but
for a one year stint as offensive line
coach with the giants at the college
level yeah well yeah he knows how to
build a team he does have great
experience really throughout the
coaching roster really right that's
what's you kind of unique about matt
rule i mean he's coached a little bit on
everything on both sides of the ball
offense and defense and i think that's
proven to be one of his strengths by the
way he built temple and baylor so to me
this also almost says too that carolina
was impressed with his vision on
building a team and what he sees and
things like that i think that's what it
speaks to and i was told by somebody
mike who's in the know too that they
made him a huge salary offer i mean
something basically where they said like
he couldn't walk out of the building and
say no and as we know david tepper has
more money than you know he knows what
to do with and i think he didn't penny
pinch penny pinch here and just went for
it but i think that's the thing that
they probably like mike he's a real
football coach he's not political he's
kind of in your face no nonsense no bs
type of guy
and he obviously understands how to
build a program and it sounds like
carolina thinks they need some building
there
and that's an intriguing angle because
david tepper one of the richest owners
there is no salary cap for coaches but
over the years there's been kind of a
loose sense that
owners limit how much they pay coaches
with bill
belichick being the one exception
if you start having some of these rich
owners blow up the pay scale some of the
other owners are not going to be happy
about it because that starts an arms
race at a position where there is no
limit on how much you pay your coaching
staff
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports